every girl out there likes to hear how
much you like or love them but they like
it even more if you show them with a
gift so in this video I'm gonna show you
the best gifts that you can get your
girlfriend on Amazon so let's get right
into the video
hey guys I'm Daniel and welcome to D LM
model lifestyle now let's start with the
first gift the first gift is the hug
pillow from Oh Susana this will be a
very popular gift especially if you're
still fresh in the relationship because
now every time when she goes to bed and
sees the pillow she'll think of you I
just say you know I'll add everything
for you that I'm going to talk about in
this video
just your innovative description down
below so it's a bit easier for you to go
and check them up next up is jewelry
because jewelry has always been and it
will always be a girl's soft spot and
remember
chocolate is good but it is car free so
check out this silver heart necklace on
Amazon for 40 bucks I'll add a few other
options for you in a video description
as well
now the girlfriend is a coffee drinker
or a tea drinker get her a special mug
or a mug set so that she will always
think of you whenever she drinks her
favorite cup of whatever so check out
this mug that says best girlfriend ever
or you can also get this kissing mug set
yeah it's almost too cheesy but most
girls like it
right now if you have a very picky
girlfriend that's very picky about
everything that she buys it might be
better to get her a nice Amazon gift
card
now most ladies love shopping especially
on the web when it is just browse all
the products so when you give her a gift
card it's almost like you're keeping her
to presents because she will enjoy this
shopping part just as much that you will
enjoy the actual gift that she chooses
perfume you can never ever go wrong with
perfume well unless it smells like
toilet spray and there are some that
smells like that so you can try Calvin
Klein euphoria it smells amazing and if
you have a classy girlfriend you can try
Elizabeth Arden Red Door for fifty five
bucks or if you're on a budget you can
try pheromone perfume for her for only
thirty bucks I'll add them for you in
the video description down below and a
few other options as well the huge teddy
bear now it doesn't matter how old they
are most ladies love a huge teddy bear
check out the June they in busy teddy
bear or if you like it even bigger the
Vermont giant teddy bear
[Music]
now if your girlfriend likes cool
gadgets that makes her life easier you
can never go wrong with that echo dot
third-generation there's a reason why
this is a best seller on Amazon the echo
dot is Amazon's most popular voice
controlled speaker now with improved
sound you can ask it to play music
answer questions read a news check the
weather set alarms and control
compatible smart home devices and much
much more - check it out right now most
of us know that we can't really buy our
girlfriend happiness but getting her a
handbag that you really likes is almost
the same thing or very close now some of
the best handbags on Amazon are Michael
Kors women's Jet Set travel back for
around 160 dollars but if you were
working with a budget or if you're not
too long in a relationship where you can
buy expensive stuff then check out this
handbag for 35 dollars from Michigan I
hope that's how you pronounce it
I'll a degree in the video description
so you can check it out
now if you're fresh in a relationship
your girlfriend might ask you for a
photo of you beat it her to it take the
best photo off you guys and put it in a
nice photo frame like this one from
elegant science
now if you're not sure what to buy get
your girlfriend a gift bag with a few
mixed items like this at-home spa gift
set for this bath and body gifts it
now for bonus tip don't just get your
girlfriend a gift on a special day like
a birthday or anniversary give it to her
when she least expects it because then
she'll appreciate the most now if you
guys liked the video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you